voltaje es una de las ideas y cantidades
más importantes de la ingeniería
eléctrica y en este vídeo vamos a
desarrollar un poco de intuición acerca
de qué significa voltaje y tiene que ver
con la energía potencial de las cargas
eléctricas y esto es lo que vamos a
cubrir en este vídeo
no vamos a verlo formalmente pero vamos
a hacer una descripción intuitiva de lo
que significa el voltaje y vamos a
empezar con una analogía a la gravedad
la gravedad y el voltaje son ideas muy
parecidas voy a dibujar una montaña por
aquí con un poco de nieve y además voy a
poner una masa por aquí aquí tenemos una
masa m que fue elevada hasta la cumbre
de la montaña de alguna forma ya sea por
un teleférico o por un alpinista o por
algo de ese estilo pero si tomamos una
masa y la colocamos aquí y luego la
dejamos caer la energía potencial que
posee se va a disipar en forma de
energía cinética y esta masa va a rodar
colina abajo hasta acá y bueno mientras
va cayendo esta masa puede hacer un poco
de trabajo puede aplastar algunos
árboles también puede pegarle a un oso
puede chocar contra otras piedras y
saltar y salir volando
un montón de cosas pero bueno esta es
una masa cayendo colina abajo por la
gravedad si nosotros ponemos por aquí
otra montaña que en este caso va a ser
el voltaje pero en esta montaña en lugar
de poner un teleférico vamos a poner una
batería y eso es justo lo que las
baterías hacen en nuestro circuito
aunque la batería lo que hace es subir
electrones hasta arriba de la montaña
así es que este es un electrón saliendo
del polo negativo de la batería ok este
es el polo negativo y este el polo
positivo y si lo suelto va a caer colina
abajo
y eventualmente va a regresar al lado
inferior de esta batería pero bueno esto
es exactamente lo mismo que tenemos
cuando construimos un circuito y a lo
largo del camino puedo hacer que el
electrón pase por distintos componentes
de circuitos como resistor eso
capacitores o cualquiera de este tipo de
cosas y puedo hacer que el electrón haga
algunos trabajos y choque contra algunas
cosas mientras va hacia abajo ahora la
cantidad de voltaje aquí es proporcional
a la altura de la montaña si tenemos un
voltaje muy alto vamos a tener una
montaña muy alta pero si tenemos un
voltaje muy bajo
vamos a tener una montaña pequeña los
electrones son empujados hasta la cima
por la batería y en su camino de regreso
van realizando algunos trabajos y es
aquí donde podemos hacer nuestro diseño
del circuito diseño de circuito y eso es
justo lo que estamos haciendo aquí
compramos baterías
y hacemos nuestro diseño de circuito y
lo estudiamos así es que pues esta es
una muy buena analogía del voltaje nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo